[Music]
he is the chairman of o'leary financial
group he is a shark tank investor he is
a friend of the show mr wonderful is
back to give us his uh i guess wrap up
on what has been a pretty impressive
year to say the least kevin will have uh
you know a little bit of a look forward
into next year as well here
lots to discuss 69th all-time high close
yesterday for the s p 500 we get the
70th all-time high intraday this morning
once the market gets open here
you know anywhere from inflation through
to you know covet we can cover a lot of
topics i want to start off though with
your take on
you know this year in general because we
were talking a little bit yesterday on
the show about how it doesn't really
feel like a 23 to 24
kind of year for the s p 500 but you
know here we are wrapping up the year at
all-time highs
it's true
and you know the question everybody is
asking now with this
mini santa claus rally occurring is are
we taking gains away from 2022 and
packing him into the last few trading
sessions in 2021 and i think the best
way to look at this as an investor is
look big picture for a moment we're
gonna print just south
of six percent gdp growth in q4
and then if you look at all the
estimates which were all over the map
for gdp growth of north america
in q1 they're under 3 percent and the
reason that variance is there is that
people just don't know how to read this
whole issue around covet in the
different versions of it and how much
impact it will have on the economy and
growth and so
here's here's the upside scenario and
probably why you want to be constructive
equities
i think what's happening right now is
the economy is going through a permanent
adjustment
through this last two years of covid
towards a more productive way to do
business most of this is direct to
consumer in every sector and more
digitization and more productivity from
technology and all kinds of other tools
that have been developed not just in the
last six months the last two years and i
always use the example the behemoth
example which is such a good one to use
globally
nike was able to get past 50 of its
sales now globally in the last 18 months
direct to consumer on every geography on
earth so they've completely changed
their model much less dependent on the
inefficiencies of retail and using all
the different technologies they've been
able to use they're going direct
consumer whether you're in phnom penh
cambodia toronto canada new york boston
doesn't matter you order your shoes
direct from them they drop right to your
door now that's really margin enhancing
because they can make as much as 80
percent gross margin and you're seeing
this right through the s p 500 so you
have to ask yourself
going into q1
is there an upside surprise and maybe
it's this maybe we continue this just
south of six percent gdp growth into q1
which is now got a print of less than
three as an estimate and we surprise
everybody with this continued
productivity moving through the entire
business channels all around the world
and that's sort of the way i'm going to
be trading into q1 i'm staying
constructive equities i'm picking all of
my power points i'm staying in
technology because i think that's where
it's going and i think there's a lot of
upside left
a lot of uh a talk heading into q1
obviously of next year focus on
inflation as well and you know the
recent changes that we had from the fed
uh you know tightening their stance on
this
give us your take here do we get you
know i even read an article on the
weekend talking about that deflation
word do we get a flood of uh oversupply
or more goods coming into the market to
offset this at some point
next year to kind of bring this back
down to earth a little bit or does it
take longer than that well the narrative
on inflation just two months ago 60 days
ago was it was being caused by
disruption in supply chain global supply
chain
and that was true but now when you start
to look the price of gasoline in cities
like san diego and san francisco north
of five dollars a gallon in the u.s and
the price of bread up 13 percent chicken
up 19 percent beef up 24
that's real inflation and that's the
result of having so much free money
coming out of helicopters for so long
including that last trillion dollar
infrastructure bill which hasn't even
hit yet now that's the negative news so
it's not just supply chain disruption
i think what's going to happen is supply
chain problems will slowly get better
through q2 and q3 and q4 not in q1
they're still big problems into the
major ports in north america
however
we saw that bill build back better bill
just basically get dead i mean it's gone
and that is very important for not
putting any more fuel on the fire
inflation the economy in north america
is on fire it doesn't need any more
stimulus and so you know for whatever
reason the checks and balance in the
system made sure that that was going to
be i thought very bad policy a really
bad idea
and it got just basically put behind
the barn and you know what happened to
it it's gone so the good news for
investors on the s p 500 is this you've
got total gridlock in washington now
nothing else is going to get done
zero the midterms will hit the incumbent
always loses a ton of seats in the house
when that happens this time for biden it
looks could be much worse
because they don't they didn't like the
the socialist swing that he was pushing
on them and he was really cow towering
to that side of the party and i don't
like to get into politics i like to get
into policy but the good news is that
bill's dead total gridlock nothing more
out of washington this is always good
for markets it it gives you more
certainty that politicians can't do
anything else for the rest of biden's
mandate great news
let's talk uh along those lines let's
talk uh crypto markets another exciting
year another very volatile year for uh
cryptocurrencies you've been very active
very vocal in this space uh this year
the the bigger conversation i guess
always seems to come back to this
adoption by institutions and and you
know the need for further regulation
give us your take paint a picture here
as we head into 2022 what happens
uh in 2022 nothing's going to happen in
the u.s market i don't think they'll
even deal with stable coins that
geography is going to go through a very
long process before it institutionalizes
crypto everybody understands that the
optimism that was around in february
last year around the first u.s etf when
the when the ets came into the canadian
market and you have to hand it to the
canadian regulator they have been very
strong in terms of innovation and
letting these new ideas of payment
systems be tested in the markets and
then adopted in their policy we just had
two new licenses granted
here in ontario they and they're pan
canadian for market exchanges that's
fantastic and that's real innovation and
the way i like to look at that and this
is just a personal opinion i don't have
any insider information or anything but
the osc has consistently been great
innovation great innovators very
expensive experimental but never did
anything outside of the purvey of the
sec they were very coordinated so in a
way canada is a bit of a guinea pig
market for what the sec looks at that's
a personal opinion so they're watching
what's happening here we're getting very
strong adoption of these various payment
systems crypto platforms
cryptocurrencies crypto infrastructure
all of that these different chains
canada is leading the charge globally in
getting investor capital which is
absolutely fantastic including mine and
other geographies are starting to look
at canada in terms of leadership in the
sense that they're not going they're not
crypto cowboys they're not going against
the sec
they're being very thoughtful so
geographies like united arab emirates i
just spent 10 days there to talk to the
government about their plans on
cryptocurrencies because i'm very
interested in investing there as well i
think for institutional investors now
the new game plan for 2022 is to find
the geographies and find the regulators
that are going to be more innovative if
you want to call it that or more liberal
if you want to use that word and invest
in those geographies why we wait while
we wait out policy in the united states
which is going to eventually happen but
you've got to be a global investor if
you want to enjoy the innovation being
done within crypto and i will always
argue this regarding crypto you know i
don't think bitcoins bitcoin i think
bitcoin is software i think ethereum is
software i think hbar is software
polygon is software i invest in all of
it it's the infrastructure of the
internet and lastly because i remember
talking to you guys at the beginning of
last year and i was saying i was
thrilled that my crypto exposure in
february and march the end of q1 was
three percent well
through more investment this year in
companies like wonder and immutable
holdings that were brought public on the
neo exchange in canada more innovation
you got to head at the neo my exposure
now across the across crypto including
my work with ftx and with circle in usdc
i'm past 10 percent that's a ton of the
operating company's capital involved in
this sector
mr kevin o'leary thank you so much for
all the insight i did actually i have a
very similar i was going to talk to you
about something else but you just made a
good point there about you're three
percent turning into 10
is that something we always hear people
talk about you know trimming once it
gets to a certain level it seems like
your conviction is pretty strong i i
have a feeling like you may be adding to
that 10
rather than trimming is that a policy
because obviously with some of the funds
is that something that you're doing
personally does it get to a level where
even though we're bullish we start to
trim back a little bit just because
we're overweighted or how do you play
that sort of aspect well that's a great
question i use the same approach i use
to equities and debt i never let one
single position become more than five
percent of the portfolio never more than
a sector ever gets past 20. so i've got
a good 10 left to go
on on crypto i'm very constructive on
crypto i'm a believer in it you have to
make a binary decision either you
believe in it you don't i'm on board so
i'm investing but i actually allocated
seven percent of the capital but capital
appreciation was so strong in the last
two quarters across a lot of these
platforms that it blew right past 10
percent i haven't trimmed anything yet
because no individual position my
largest right now is ethereum but i also
own a lot of solana a lot of polygon
polygon guys i met in dubai i was so
impressed with their whole technology of
aggregating transactions on top of
ethereum and then reducing gas fees or
costs dramatically at any time you can
add efficiency you can reduce friction
reduce costs be more productive you want
to invest in teams that do that so i
invested in them as well i'm just
finding you know i look at deal flow
right now 45 of my day in looking at new
deals is in the crypto space that's
almost half so i'm going to continue to
be very constructive in 2022 i'm very
excited about innovation there
and of course polygon matic uh that's
that's the name that we've been into a
lot and i i bought an nft the other day
and it was like the price of gas on
ethereum was almost the same as the nfd
itself so i think you're right uh on
some of those plays a little bit of a
personal question uh of course because
we were trolling your social media and
when it came up i was like oh man that's
a place i want to go to how was blue
blood at casa loma what did you have
there i've heard some you know good
ratings from them what was your opinion
of blue blood
first of all you know i i was so
impressed with the staff because in the
middle of this outbreak of this new you
know version of kovid which is very
contagious they had figured out how to
lay out that restaurant with plexiglass
and everything else it was
just just done beautifully the food
there is spectacular i mean it is a
treasure in toronto because it's the
castle vibe it's just absolutely
spectacular and the wine list was and of
course i drank too much wine but i got
to tell you it was because the wine list
was so fantastic started with you know
an american cab and then went into
a beautiful mantra shea i mean they
the guy that runs that place nick and
his wife
have done a fantastic job i mean he's a
great restaurateur and it reflects in
the quality of the staff there loved it
i'll be going back for sure you know i'm
gushing overflowing because i had a
great experience i brought my whole
family they loved it fantastic
i see one problem though my wife is here
in the chat and now i have to take her
so maybe i'll have to get you up with a
uh a little reservation there but uh
yeah that's fantastic
one big question so i sort of put out a
tweet what did you what did everyone
want me to ask you and really the main
thing that i think is important to us we
have a lot of
young aspiring what i believe talented
individuals in our chat they bring us
great ideas with stocks things like that
you know what was your sort of aha
moment maybe when you decided and you
always talk about success comes from
within empower yourself do it yourself
at what stage maybe of your career did
you sort of say you know what this is
what i want to get into you know i want
to be this businessman i want to you
know when when did this happen was it
early was it late because we do have a
lot of different age ranges here on our
viewership and they always are asking
like they're trying to get motivated
sometimes they stumble you know what was
sort of was there an aha moment for you
did something click you know is there
anything you want to talk about maybe on
this topic
sure and i this is i think advice for
you know all people that
you know entrepreneurship and working
for yourself and becoming an investor
has nothing to do with the greed of
money it's all about the pursuit of
personal freedom the reason i do what i
do
is because i want to be able to choose
how i spend my time i never worked for
anybody for most of my life because i
got fired when i was a teenager in an
ice cream store in ottawa canada and it
was so humbling to realize that that
woman had such power over me that i
never wanted to do it again and i of
course have to thank her because she
took me on a different journey it's not
for everybody there's nothing wrong for
working for other people but i just
can't do it i don't know how to do it i
don't know how to listen to somebody
else telling me what to do it just
doesn't make sense to me i have to
decide that for myself and that took me
on my path at a young age it's not an
easy road but you know what you find out
when you get your first deal and you're
successful with that you just work
harder i don't need more money i need
more time but i love to work with young
entrepreneurs i've got over 35 private
companies now and i fly all over the
world to meet my ceos it's fantastic and
i really enjoy it my wife thinks i'm
crazy but you know
i met her when i had no money we when we
got married we couldn't even afford you
know a wedding hall we had pizza in our
house i don't think she's complaining
right now anymore
kevin you and i are very alike in many
many ways my friend um shout out to both
our wives uh i don't know if yours is
watching mine is so now i've already
talked about that uh a couple of times
there how's the watch collected i still
got the submariner i'm trying to you
know i'm trying to make some moves here
in the market i'm trying to get up to
your collection anything hot for 2022 in
the watch game yeah that the breakout
brand that went from a micro brand uh
you know to now
head of the pack in terms of capital
appreciation is fp jordan and fp jorn in
2021
just went insane and you know i happen
to be wearing one right now that this is
the putin watch it's called the blue
this was a this was an entry-level
journey watch just two years ago you
could have picked it up for about 17 000
maybe 18 000. today you can't buy one
for 110 000. that gives you an idea of
how the journey brand has exploded and
it's it's really the watch to to look
for it's going to continue this trend
because the jordan society buys 87 of
his pieces so he's got such a following
and the best way to look at it if you
can get your hands on one is this is the
living picasso
of watchmaking one day he won't be on
earth anymore and anything you own that
he made when he was alive is going to be
worth you know he's the andy warhol he's
the picasso he he's the michelangelo
that guy is walking the earth right now
making watches and if there's any way
you can get one it's worth doing
yeah i'm not sure i'll be able to get my
hands on one of those but thank you for
sharing uh all of your experiences and
some great advice really love with this
interview and hope you'll be able to
come back to us uh in 2022 enjoy the
rest of this time uh with your family
kevin i'm going to throw you back to
brendan thanks again
great stuff uh before we let you go we
don't want to take up too much of your
time kevin let's let's look forward as
far as the market is concerned going
into next year i i just thread a static
nasdaq underperforming the np 500 for
the first time since 2016 this year when
it seems like all you hear about is tech
stocks and tech headlines leading the
market so a little bit of you know maybe
a surprising year this year what are you
excited about heading into next year
i think tech will remain volatile i
think the fed will move in with rate
hikes which just
necessarily doesn't kill bull markets
because it indicates strong underlying
economy
but it really makes you want to be
constructive in equities versus fixed
income
i think that's going to be the challenge
i've changed my weighting at the
beginning of last year from 50 50 fixed
income and equity to 70 30 and now with
crypto in the mix as well i've reduced
even more of my exposure to fixed income
because if you're in cash for example
and i'm not telling people not to be in
cash but you're basically being taxed at
six percent that's inflation right now
so you've got to find other places
deploy capital depending on where you
are in the risk curve and so i'm looking
again at real estate i'm looking again
at hard assets i'm gold i'm crypto i'm
trying to find places where i'm not
going to lose six percent in 12 months
because i think inflation is going to be
around and you've got to be constructive
you want to look at high quality balance
sheets for the majority of your
portfolio you want to look very hard at
their ability to continue generating
cash and distributing it through
dividends and you know there's every
once in a while you get a gift and i
recently increased my exposure to disney
everybody hates it right now but it's a
behemoth in terms of being able to grow
with its franchises and look i may be
wrong at the beginning but long term i
like it because of its balance sheet and
eventually we'll get rid of this
pandemic and that will help disney
obviously but you have to pick where you
want to be
and and i think you want to really
really be a stock picker in 2022 as
opposed to just buying indexes unless
you can find indexes that are are
actually uh you know
smart in terms of being rule-based
staying away from the airlines for
example you look at united it had eight
seven or eight billion in debt
pre-pandemic the things got over 20
billion now it's an upside down balance
sheet why would you own why would you
want to own that you got to avoid those
kind of disasters if you like that video
wait you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe